all right so yes we have to talk about
it the donald trump's health story has
gone
mainstream and i want to be really
careful with the story because
donald trump is denying something that
has not actually been
alleged and that is extremely suspicious
but i don't want to be alleging that
thing i think you're going to understand
momentarily here so over the last
several years
there have been general health concerns
about the president
what's going on with his cognitive state
you've got these twitches and spasms
that coincide with verbal glitches
you sometimes have upper trump and
sometimes downer trump he often seems
confused
he sometimes slurs without a real
explanation
we've seen him dragging his right leg
while walking
we've seen donald trump sort of unable
to just speak normally
talking about the oranges of an
investigation and so on and so forth
and then we had in 2019 that abrupt
visit to walter reed hospital
which we were told was merely trump
deciding
on the on a weekend that he had a few
extra hours in his day
so he would show up at walter reed and
get a job
pass the sniff test at the time well
there is a new book
coming from new york times reporter
michael schmidt
which says that visit to walter reed
was not trump saying let's get a jump on
my physical
that it was some kind of
abrupt visit due to something medical
that happened with donald trump
and it was serious enough that vice
president mike pence was told
trump may need to be put under
anesthesia be on standby
in case you need to take over for some
period of time
those are the allegations from michael
schmidt so
the suspicions always were trump wasn't
there for his physical
and the book claims to corroborate that
now
um this would not be typical if donald
it wouldn't be typical for mike pence to
be put on standby
in case trump has to be put under
anesthesia if trump's really going for a
physical that wouldn't be normal
for a physical so that's so far okay
there's been an allegation made
that that visit was was some kind of
medical incident
donald trump tweets out of nowhere that
he hasn't
suffered many strokes now you might say
why is trump tweeting about many strokes
michael schmidt didn't say anything
about many strokes well that's exactly
the question donald trump tweeting quote
it never ends now they are trying to say
that your favorite president
me went to walter reed medical center
having suffered a series of mini strokes
never happened to this candidate fake
news
perhaps they are referring to another
candidate from another party
now this is disinformation it has not
been
alleged that trump has been suffering
many strokes let me be clear
people on twitter have alleged it but
the point is
it is not part of michael schmidt's
forthcoming book that trump suffered
many strokes trump is out of nowhere
saying
that something didn't happen which no
one has alleged this would be like
if someone went to the hospital and you
say hey
did you go to the hospital for uh
routine blood work or did something
happen
and you say i didn't have a heart attack
i definitely didn't have a heart attack
it would raise
suspicion if you start denying something
that wasn't alleged
and in fact it raises more questions
than it answers now i got an email from
uh daniel who's a viewer who says my
mother is a board-certified
neurologist i showed her a few clips of
trump's foot dragging slurred speech etc
and she was fairly certain he had a mild
stroke recently possibly the night he
was rushed to walter reed hospital
so when presented with some of the video
uh of trump you can certainly find
medical professionals who would
who would ask about something like a
stroke but it is not
actually what the book alleges now we
also regularly see video as is mentioned
in the email
of donald trump walking and kind of
dragging his right foot
not picking it up completely as he walks
it is true that such video exists but
again
it is not proof of anything so here's my
take on this
we should be careful not to claim
anything happened when we don't know
that it did
yes the visit to walter reed was weird
yes it never passed the sniff test that
trump was getting ahead on his 2020
physical
yes trump bringing up strokes when they
haven't been mentioned
is extraordinarily odd uh but we really
need to get actual answers about why
donald trump went to the hospital
and um if it was for a physical there
would be no reason
that he would be placed under anesthesia
that that he would be expected to go
under anesthesia
and there would be no reason for mike
pence to be told be at the ready
so it is gaslighting for trump to deny
having a stroke because it hasn't been
alleged
and yet it is suspicious that trump is
focusing in on strokes particularly
since it's not something that has been
mentioned so it would be great if at
some point
because i do think that as a general
principle
the voting public has a right to know
about the real health status
of people who may be arguably the most
powerful people in the world
or among them i do think the public has
a right to know
and the white house should just come
clean about the reason for that visit
adding fuel to the fire of suspicion is
that when asked
about this mike pence's answer was
it was certainly squirrely slippery let
me put it that way
and that's what i want to talk about
next if you love
feeding your intellectual curiosity but
you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories
and a subscription is only about eight
bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video